la présence du maréchal à
bourg-en-bresse et salué avec
l'affection débarrasse de tout un peuple
et quand le maréchal se penche sur des
berceaux c'est à l'avenir de la france
que sont nos crochets et l'on assiste
ensuite aux offrandes symbolique gage
naïve quelquefois témoignage d'amour et
de reconnaissance
lien vivant de cette communauté que le
marichal exprimé lui-même en disant de
la poule fait de chaque commune une
grande famille où tout le monde
travaille dans un effort commun
fraternité française
jamais sans doute ce monde à trouver une
plus que dans ce retour des prisonniers
de la région d'ivoire